- On today's episode,
Oliver stops by.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them
this is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 234 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
We've been on a major hiatus
and we have a guest
which I'm excited about.
- Really excited.
- Before we get into Oliver and
his new book and all that stuff
and the questions from Dunk,
I just want to say
what's up to everybody.
A lot of you asked if
I stopped the show.
I haven't.
I was in LA,
I'm filming my show,
my Apple TV show
over there just a lot of--
- Gone all Hollywood on us.
- Got a little Hollywood
on you guys and
then I was just
traveling before.
I'm just busy being
the CEO, you know,
I don't do #AskGaryVee on
location so and even in the
weeks that I was here bunch of
business decisions going
into the fourth quarter and
New Year's so I just
been working my time.
- Big election.
- (laughs) Big election.
There's been a lot going.
Jets suck shit.
There's been a lot going on so a
lot going on but before we get
into the show, Oliver why
don't you create some context.
Obviously, we've been
running in similar circles.
- We were on CNBC
together one time.
- I remember that.
- With the Nervo Girls.
- That was fun.
I remember that.
You've had a really, you
know, great digital career.
- Thank you.
- I've heard your name a
whole bunch through the years.
We haven't had the pleasure
really jammed together so I'm
excited about this but a quick
one minute bio and then we'll go
into this and then we'll
answer some questions.
- Sure. Yeah, I started off in
technology and voice over the
internet and video for the
internet with Revver and then as
technology started going
in to Hollywood and in to
entertainment built the last
company was called The Audience.
Before that I was,
I hated the title,
but I was head of innovation at
Disney so I really brought that
brand into social media.
You know, broke it into
all the characters and
into the attractions.
- So much so that Bob felt
comfortable giving you a quote
on the front cover which is
always an indicator did the
person do a good job while
they were at the company.
- Yeah, it's a little
nerve-racking when you reach
back out to these
people if you've left.
- By the way, I look at that.
- What'd they really think?
- I look at that
because you know
I've seen it a bunch of times.
I was the head of
this at, you know,
at Nike and then they're doing
something and nobody
from Nike saying anything.
So when I saw that
I'm like hmmm. Alright.
- Yeah, no, that's exciting and
then wrote this book over the
last year and half kind of
really naturally evolved with
Michael Casey, who is a editor
at the Wall Street Journal.
We met on Nekker Island
which is Branson's island.
I was a speaker there.
He came up to me
afterwards and was like,
"I think this really resonates
and I think you couldn't have
"better timing," and it was
right as I was selling
The Audience so
it all worked out great.
- Good for you, man.
- I'm very happy about it and
thank you for having me.
- So you know, yeah, no worries.
What is this book and
what's the premise?
- "The Social Organism"
most people see it as orgasm.
- That's what I saw actually.
I literally thought
that's what it said.
- So, I'm always the
first disappoint.
- I can't read either.
- Anyone with dyslexia--
- Yeah, I'm dead.
- they get really
excited about it.
- I thought this was
like a social orgy.
I didn't even read it right.
- Well, orgies are social.
- Fair enough.
Yes, fair.
- So it fits.
- So go ahead.
- No, but it's a book that is a
lot of different concepts that
came together and I was asked
one time to draw
the future of social.
Details Magazine had said I was
this digital maverick and those
things are cringe worthy, as
you know, and so they asked me
to draw the future of social and
the only thing I know how to
draw was when I was a little kid
I was super nerd and I studied
molecular and cell biology and
worked in the research lab so
I know how to draw pathways.
Like when you cut yourself
how bleeding stops through the
arachidonic acid pathway and
then I went into telecom--
- I figured that would
come up in this conversation.
- Yeah, exactly.
This is deep shit over here.
And then in the telecom world
I knew how to draw routers and
switches and things like
that but none of them,
even combine those ideas,
none of them could
explain it in any depth.
As you know, it's a very
complicated almost soup of
inputs and outputs and people's
reactions and so I just had this
moment where I realized that
maybe the only way to explain it
is to look at it very
practically and say look this
is really 1.3 billion organisms
connected together over a
network that has no time and
distance because of TCP/IP so
maybe it behaves like one
organism and so
the metaphor stuck.
And so I started going back,
I literally went back to my old
biology textbook and looked at
the seven rules of life and
sure enough it fits
every one of them.
- And that's how you--
- You nourish the system,
emotions are the
metabolism of it
and so I structured it like
a term paper and you know the
publisher, once Michael came on
board we actually turned it into
a book as opposed to
an academic paper.
- And so, what do
they get out of this?
As I'm thinking about so
many people that follow this,
care about social media,
things of that nature,
what do they get out of this
that they don't get from my
books, they don't get from other
books or what's the complement,
where's the cross-section,
what's the punchline and then
we'll go into the--?
- Yeah, it's
totally complementary.
It's a little bit
more of a macro view.
It's almost like--
- The thesis?
- It's the thesis.
It's really like if
you want to build,
we agree on so many things.
If you want to build a
career you have to nourish it,
you have to feed it.
If you want to build a brand you
have to set a set of values and
match those with the right
people and so it's really about
at a macro-level patterns that
exist in nature and how those
patterns are dealt with whether
they are viruses or diseases--
- And you talk through it?
- I do.
- Case studies?
- It's from my
personal experience.
The book starts off with my
father and Morgan Freeman are
best friends and we grew up in a
very poor place in Mississippi
and for 26 years of my life
I watched them fight
the Confederate flag.
- Right.
- And so the book starts off
with a moment when Dylan Roof,
who I just went on on I guess he
was now competent to serve as an
adult or as a
mentally stable person,
but when he went
into the church in
Charleston, South Carolina
and massacred nine people.
- Yes.
- And then suddenly overnight,
after those images of him with
the Confederate
flag hit social media,
overnight we all viewed the
Confederate flag maybe as a
symbol of hatred and racism and
overnight Amazon took it down,
eBay took it down, the state
capital started taking down,
the hashtag #takeitdown,
the woman Bree
climbed up the flagpole
and became a meme.
- Yep.
- So I looked at that
moment, I was like,
"Well, what happened?"
Right?
What is it that causes almost
an immunological response and in
immunology it's key to recognize
something as bad
before it can fix it.
And so a lot of the book talks
about how do you teach your body
or how do you teach this
system, this social organism,
to recognize the bad or
recognize the good and then
eliminate it using
your own immunology.
Because if you think
about it cellular,
it's 1.3 billion cells.
The only way an idea spreads is
if one of those cell spreads it
to the other.
- Absolutely, uh-huh.
- So it's like how do we
have the responsibility to be a
citizen within this and
to keep bad ideas down and
good ideas and to
learn how to ferret them?
And so, it's a macro-level but
you can take away from it how to
grow a content business,
how to grow a real business.
The metaphors continue--
- Play out.
- They play out and
writing the book was really an
experience 'cause we, literally,
a year and half ago said okay
now we're gonna put
a punctuation mark,
we're gonna write
this book together and
the stories just unfolded.
- Sure.
- You know, whether it was the
world moved and once we looked
in that lens, it made sense.
People's reaction to
it has been stunning.
Very few people have
it in their hands.
It's only been out a week and
half now although we had great
sales success in the first month
going into it pre-sales but
people's feedback to me is
really meaningful
right now because--
- Like you're best friend from
high school and your aunt or--
- No, it's like the woman who
worked on the trailer who got
the book a month early who I've
never met before but worked on
the book trailer and she came
up to me the other day said,
"I've read this book twice and
"I look at the world
differently now."
- That's good.
- And that's that's a
pretty meaningful response.
- That's an accomplishment.
- That's all I can ask for.
- Good for you, man.
- So I'm really happy about it.
- Congrats.
- And you live in Iceland now.
- I do. I live in Iceland.
- There's also that.
- In Reykjavik.
- We'll get to that in a minute.
- Yeah.
- Dunk, it's time for
you to say something.
- [DRock] Hold on.
- [Dunk] Hi.
- Uh-oh, you're
keeping this part in.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Okay.
This is why I can't wear
these kind of sweaters.
- [DRock] Yeah,
this sweater sucks.
- Yeah, sorry.
- [DRock] It's okay.
- Alright.
- [Dunk] First question.
- Go ahead.
- Hey Gary.
I'm wondering what you think of
Snapchat and their recent way of
selling their Spectacles, the
glasses with the vending machine
and how you think that plays
in their marketing strategy?
Thanks so much.
- Oliver, Snapchat Spectacles.
- I think they're
kind of brilliant.
I think they took something that
Google spent so much time and
energy on but effectively was
pretty nerdy and
they made it cool.
- Yep.
- Pop-up stores and
vending machines
are social media worthy.
- The distribution's been crazy.
- Yeah, exactly and if you
only have a small amount
of them then make it special.
- That's right.
- So I saw a bunch on social
media last night about a store
in New York that just popped up.
- Yep.
- Yeah, I think it's cool.
- I think it's a big play.
I think it could be maybe the
saving grace move to their IPO.
- Sure.
- If you think about what
Instagram's replication of a lot
of their functionality has done
it's created a scenario where
there's little more skeptics
talking about Snapchat's growth.
- Sure.
- A lot of people
talking about their decline.
- Instagram sucks
out the oxygen
out of the room with stories.
- So it becomes
Snap and to play,
to me what's most interesting
is Snapchat is the first social
network that feels like a brand.
- Mhmmm.
- You know, Snapchat
feels as much to me as
Under Armour and Soul Cycle--
- Yep.
- as it does Facebook or
Instagram and that crossover
from just utility social network
to overall brand I feel like
this captured that moment and if
they can pull that all the way
through well then they
really have something.
- And they really made it
where you are the media, right?
- 100%.
- And so that was part of
this exciting brand and then the
filters and the tools
and the creativity--
- And then you
think about the live.
All they have to do is add an
update that allows that be live
streaming and now all of a
sudden you got a whole thing.
I'm pretty bullish on it.
It's early, I do agree that
they've made it cool what was
$1500 and not cool from Google,
three years ago so we'll see.
Evan, from me from afar,
continues to deploy
LA brand behavior in
a San Francisco,
Silicon Valley world
in a very good way.
- Yep and they also making big
steps to be a media company.
So you saw where they stopped
rev sharing and started buying
content now as a
Netflix would do--
- The garden walls of the
internet are popping up.
- Yeah.
- Let's keep it going.
- [Dunk] Next
question is from John.
- John.
- What's going on, Gary?
This is John Max here.
I had a question for you.
Was driving and listening to
"Thank You Economy" and at the
end of the book you talk about
how you would wish the self,
the book with self-destruct by
2015 because marketers would
have ruined the
thank you economy.
Looking back do you think that
we still live in a
thank you economy?
And if not, what kind of
economy do we live in now?
Thank you.
- I'll take a little bit of
this because I'll help you.
The "Thank You Economy"'s
premise is pretty simple which
is can we scale
one-on-one behavior?
What's depth verse width, right?
You think of influencers
a place that
you and I both played.
You can have a million followers
but if you said go by this book,
both you and I know that
somebody with 72,000 followers
could sell more books, depth.
It didn't play out the way
wanted because I had optimism in
a place where I shouldn't which
is the punchline is businesses
don't get a fuck.
- No (laughs).
- It is unbelievable how much
people don't understand
why my whole world has worked.
My little thing works
because I just want to go deep.
I just want to deliver value
and it works every time and the
person who scaled the thank you
economy the best in my opinion
is Taylor Swift and
that's why she's winning.
She understands--
- We talk about her
in the book actually.
- That's great, so great
segue perfect I'm glad
we can pass the baton.
- Buy the book.
- Do some kind of
scary thing there,
by the way. Edit.
I think Taylor understands
that going to somebody's wedding
randomly may cost her 45 minutes
and not have in an ROI positive
game but it does
because the pickup,
the amplification, dropping a
pop-up shop for these glasses
for Snapchat in the
Grand Canyon is not ROI positive
until everybody talks
about it through
this kind of infrastructure
and then it does.
Thank you economy has a lot of
DNA ties to this and to your
question the reason it didn't
play out the way I'd hoped or
inspired is
companies are short-term,
I'm long-term and people that
are thinking in 20 and 30 and
40 year terms are thinking about
LTV and lifetime value and then
do things that don't have
value in the short term.
The reality is 99% of the
players don't play that way.
- You and I have been
in the same business and
I think had the same values.
It's remarkably frustrating when
you try to convince a brand to
do what you're talk about,
to go deep and actually attach
yourself to a set of values or
people that have those values.
I would say make the
content that matters,
put it in front of people it
matters to from voices
that matter to them
at a time that matters.
It's like very simple
and they never get it.
And they only want the top 1%
of people and it's
like their trophy bag.
And they're like well I got
Demi Lovato to tweet about it.
It's like, well, that
really doesn't mean anything.
- Right, Demi.
- No, it is not, I don't.
- I'm kidding,
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- She's a mass media artist
but if I'm making a purchase
decision than I want
something that's closer to me.
I want something that I trust
and feel some sense of shared
values with and these big macro
brands but Taylor she kinda over
came that by these
personal experiences.
- She understood it.
- Yep.
- She understands
there's an amplification,
scaling the unscalable.
- Just this weekend she's
singing Thanksgiving songs with
Todrick Hall who's, you know,
a self-made YouTuber who--
- She gets it. She understands
where the attention is.
She deploys unscalable behavior
in it which then
means it gets amplified.
- Yep.
- What's his name
again one more time?
- [Dunk] John.
- John.
John, all of what you
heard in that book is still an
opportunity today as it was
six years ago when I wrote it.
Let's move on.
- [Dunk] Next
question is from CK.
- CK.
- [Dunk] Yep.
- Who used some good emojis.
(crowd cheering)
- Hey Gary!
It's CK here.
Presenter, photographer
from Sheffield, UK.
My question for you how mindful
are you of differentiation when
it comes to personal branding?
There's a million and one
entrepreneurs out there,
not all of them
swear like a judge,
like you do.
Not all of them wear
trainers like you and
not all of them wear cool jeans.
So my question,
not all of them
want to buy the Jets.
So how conscious are you, Gary,
of your unique selling point
when creating your brand?
Epic, you're a hero.
Next time you're in London I
want to do a photo shoot for ya.
Let's hear it for Gary!
(crowd cheers)
- CK, I'll answer
that in a minute.
From what you've
seen Oliver, what,
you've worked with a
lot of influencers.
You've got a lot of great
connections in Hollywood.
You knew the
influencers were coming,
you knew the old school,
you knew the new school.
How do you see that?
Do you think that people
are being thoughtful of
their differentiations?
- Yeah, absolutely.
I mean look, you know, the
really smart ones understand the
idea of authenticity, right?
And understand and so I remember
sitting down with a bunch of
celebrities when Facebook pages
were really scary to them and
whether or not it was gonna be,
me the actress or me the actor
or me you know the guy
that hung out with you at
high school, I didn't really
know what persona
to do or what to present.
- And people still, a lot of
people right here are like
should I have a business page?
- Sure. Sure.
- Should I have
my personal page?
I have a job but I also
want to be known as the
funny, vulgar, juggler but
I'm a lawyer by day.
Everybody's in this
Clark Kent/Superman issue on
Facebook and social in general.
- I always profess that
you could have two lives.
You could have this public
persona that could be safe to do
this and then you have a
private existence here which is
important because we are all
stepping onto a public stage now
and there are things that should
be kept public and things that
are private and I think
we're all always in a constant
collision course with that.
Few too many drinks and a
Twitter account you can pretty
much fuck up your life.
- I agree with you and here's my
point or people forget like BP
dumped all the oil in the world
in to the and people forget.
It's amazing what, I don't
think anybody's talking about
like all these actors and
actresses and athletes have
so many mistakes and issues.
America is quite forgiving.
What we're not forgiving
about is the cover-up.
- The hypocrisy.
- That's right.
- People don't like hypocrisy.
- It is a death blow,
it is a death blow.
- In Iceland, we overthrew the
government in a 24 hour period,
and a long-standing system of
government there because we had
a Prime Minister who
really didn't break the law
but was a hypocrite.
- That's right.
- And nobody likes a hypocrite.
Nobody likes a hypocrite.
- I'm familiar with that
story and you're right.
From my standpoint, here's
where I've been thoughtful,
seven years ago I decided that
there was something inside of me
and the new mediums
were in my favor,
that good things
were about to happen
and I better just be me
all the way through.
- Yep.
- A level of transparency and
authenticity that was extreme
because I made the assumption
that it was gonna really work
out and that everybody on
Earth would know who I was.
I still knew I wanted
to be a businessman.
I didn't want to be an actor.
- You're getting close.
- But I knew that, I made a
video seven or eight years,
you should edit this in that
said that technology was
gonna be hip hop.
That we were in this
1985 hip hop moment.
Serious, hip hop '85 is
equal to tech web 2.0 2008.
That Zucks and Kevin Rose
and all these people,
these were people
that were gonna,
look I basically think I said in
the video or I said it elsewhere
that tech founders were gonna
marry supermodels and like
Evan Spiegel's doing that.
- That is absolutely happening.
- And so I knew that then,
I thought that would happen to
me and so I've been conscious of
the following which is you guys
really know my shit.
Now that being said,
I have a counterpoint.
There is very little content
on my family in the world.
- Yeah, I noticed you
mentioned that in your last--
- Xander, my little guy,
I don't think anybody even
knows what he looks like.
I don't think there's
one piece of content.
So you gotta pick and
choose what's important to you.
- Yep.
- For Lizzie and I, it's
important the kids don't have
that exposure and they choose,
I think Misha's gonna choose.
I think she's gonna
be a YouTube kid star.
(Olivers laughs)
We need to let them choose
but you're in full control.
- You're the dad-anger.
- Exactly, I can't
wait to be a dad-anger.
I'm gonna negotiate good deals.
Alright, let's move it on.
- [Dunk] Next
question is from Miguel.
- Miguel.
- Hey Gary, my
name is Miguel Ogas.
For some context, I work
in a full-time ministry.
I run a network of churches
for my lead pastor where I'm
traveling about twice a month
and you have inspired me to give
my wife my laptop computer
so I do all of my business
full-time through the phone.
I believe everything you're
saying about the future of the
cell phone so I just want to
figure out how to do it right.
So my question to you is
this, what are some tips,
tricks, apps, any type of hustle
advice you can give to somebody
who wants to run a network,
run a business completely 100%
through the phone no
longer using a laptop?
Thank you for all you do.
Appreciate you.
- Have you seen
the Google phone?
- The Pixel?
- The Pixel.
- I haven't seen it.
- It's amazing.
- Do you have it?
- I have two of them, yeah.
- And so what?
Have you made the
jump to phone only?
- 100%. 100%.
- You have no laptop?
You have one--
- I rarely use, I have a laptop
which I'm like if I have to
download a bunch of,
like right now
I'm downloading a
bunch of photos.
- Google has such a
great suite of products--
- It's amazing.
- they made, I assume, Doc
and Mail and Calendar--
- It's amazing.
It's like intuitive and
smart and and it's like
you'll have an
appointment and it's like,
"Would you like to add
this to your contact book?"
It's like improving
itself the whole time.
- Such a miss by Microsoft.
I thought two years ago--
- I had that phone,
I loved that phone.
- I thought Microsoft, when it
was when it's dead in cell phone
world, I thought they should
have come out with the Microsoft
phone that was built to be you
know the business engine
that it sounds
Google has executed.
From my standpoint,
there's only one smart hack.
I can talk all about everything.
Different apps, here's the
reason it works for me:
anything that isn't great on
the phone you scale through
another human being.
If you're able to afford
an admin which or use some
AI assistance and
things of that nature,
I don't write, as my
team will tell you,
I don't write any...
My emails are one word
or like an emoji.
I do so little actual work that
if you're working in
Excel sheets and Word
and PowerPoint and these things
it may be a little trickier.
As somebody who doesn't, as
somebody who has like the team
send "Here's the proposal. Can
you approve it?" and as soon as
I get it I write approved and
they're like you didn't open it.
We can see that
you didn't open it.
I said approved,
mother fucker. You know?
And so, I think you have to
know yourself but I think the
human element of having an admin
or somebody else to close the
shortcoming but I think living
in a mobile only environment.
- Sometimes I add a few
words because I'm the same way.
I'm like, "Thank you,
approved. Good."
- Yeah.
- "Great."
And they're like,
"I just wrote a treatise."
I'm like, "Well, maybe you
can slim it down a little bit."
- It's the biggest
inside joke here.
People write seven paragraphs
and I write back the
thumbs up emoji.
And they're like, fuck.
- It's like can I get a
little more feedback here.
- Something!
- Something.
I worked on this.
Alright, let's move it.
- [Dunk] Last one.
- Last one.
- [Dunk] From Cory.
- Cory.
- Gary, what's going on?
It's Captain Cory
from CaptCory.tv and
the Captain's Vlog on YouTube.
I'm in the back of the airplane
because it's more quiet but
I got a couple
questions for you.
First off, Gary aside for your
incredible interpersonal skills,
what would you say is the most
important leadership quality
that you deploy amongst
those that you lead?
And the second part
of that question,
what are two important
leadership qualities that we as
young leaders can develop
that'll make us more effective
as leaders and have a greater
influence and make a bigger
difference amongst those?
Appreciate all you do.
Love the show.
I'm not watching as much any
more 'cause I'm grinding and
hustling but love it.
Love what you do, man.
If you ever need
a ride too, man,
let me know.
- That's good.
That's my big thesis
by the way, Oliver.
Unlike a lot of people,
I actually want my audience
of people to decline--
- Sure.
- because I want to inspire
people to actually go do.
- Right.
- The amount of
reading all our books,
watching all our stuff,
that's fine and I like that.
- Yep. My tagline's always
been I get shit done.
Just get it done.
- You've been a successful
leader in your companies,
what's the biggest thing
that has really worked for you?
- I think being humanistic which
is a word that I don't think
many people, especially
in this country, use.
But there's a real value
to putting humans first.
And it sounds so trite but
there's a real value to having
empathy and putting humans
first and looking at them from a
perspective that you can
say, how do I help you grow?
What is both this sympathy parts
and the nourishment parts that
are going to help you realize
your potential as a person?
And I've started
seven companies now
and made a lot of mistakes.
Human resources is the hardest
thing to do at scaling a
company because I always make
the joke they are neither a
resource nor human,
human resources.
And so--
- That's why the head of mine
is called Chief Heart
Officer, Claude.
Claude is the number two
person in this company
and everybody knows it.
It is the foundation at
Vayner because we sell people.
- Yep, exactly and so, I mean
you're in a service business,
in a content business so
that makes sense and so I think
taking a lens of humanism has
been the biggest gift for me.
It's one of the reasons
I moved to Iceland.
You have a humanistic society
that doesn't punish people
for their weaknesses.
- I like that.
- You have no poverty,
you have no homelessness.
You have reform
instead of prison.
Big, important things especially
coming from a place like
Mississippi where I was born.
You look at that and
that's a place where
people are not
treated like humans.
There are systems in place.
I remember with American Express
we made a movie called "Spent"
about payday lenders in America.
Talk about your
audience and the pains.
That's $1 trillion business
in America that is parasitic.
- Yep.
- It adds no value to
the system whatsoever.
In Iceland, a human human right
is to be able to
access your money.
- Sure.
- Here we have the basic
principles of our economy are
inaccessible in my hometown to
80% of the people have to go to
a payday lender and a check
cashing place and spend a
percentage of their income just
to take just to be able
to spend their money.
That is not humanistic.
That is counter to anything
that will help a system
grow and evolve.
- I couldn't agree
more with the human--
- Not to rant about
payday lenders but fuck--
- but it's a valid point and
I think from my standpoint it's
listening and
it's self-awareness.
I think the biggest mistake
charismatic CEOs make is they
try to fake the funk and act
like they know everything.
- Mhmmm.
- I always feel like I think
I know everything and
lot of you leave
comments about ego.
Only 'cause I stay in my lane.
There's a very narrow
world where I'm very good.
I tend to never go out of it.
You notice how
I have social media and
business people
on the show.
This is not a healthcare expert.
We're not talking about
hair dying activities.
This is not, nobody's gonna be
on the show talking about how to
raise cattle because I'm not
gonna put myself in a position
where I do not know what
the fuck I am talking about.
- Right.
- And so being all-in on what
you know and then being very
empathetic and listening and
deploying humility against
the things you don't know.
People pick up on
that real, real, real fast.
Because when you come across
somebody that works for you that
does know the thing that
your bullshitting about and
you bullshit it,
you just lost a winner.
- Yep.
- You've just lost a winner.
- It's about building
that trusted relationship
at every level of all of this.
- I got to get the
hell out of here.
I like your pants.
- Thank you.
- Question of the day.
- Yep.
- And by the way,
great meeting you.
I want you guys to
actually hear this.
This is actually, we actually
deployed what we believe in.
One minute, I promise.
We've done a CNBC
thing together once.
We know about each other because
we've been running in circles--
- Sure.
- He sends an email, we're busy
as shit and the answer was yes.
- Yep.
- I know how this feels.
You know, I know
this has an audience.
I knew it could help.
I felt very comfortable to pay
forward and create opportunity
for the exposure 'cause
it's a smart thing to do.
- Thank you.
- Anyway, question of the day.
You get to ask any question.
There'll be a thousand answers
between YouTube and Facebook
might give you some consumer
insights or whatever you're up
to or whatever you want.
Ask the question of the day.
- Question of the day, hmmm...
- You could ask what
your favorite color is.
You can go very escapism.
- No, that's not
what I want to ask.
I want to do
something thoughtful.
- Good.
- I know because this whole book
was about the most inspirational
person in my life that changed
my life the most was my science
teacher who saw me as this
remarkably disruptive kid and
took me out of high school
and put me in a research lab.
That's I know all
this shit about biology.
So who is the most influential
person in your life and why?
There you go.
Thank you, buddy.
It's great seeing you.
- Good luck to you.
Really good to see you.
- Thank you.